c'est au pied de ses collines
majestueuses en plein désert qu'une
petite communauté s'est formée à Revel
et futal
ici on vit au rythme du désert on
dépasse pas les 40 km/h ils sont plus de
2000 avoir succombé au charme de
l'Arizona
si elle a fini ses couches de soleil
lumineux
les puits sèches oui
le 1er janvier le maire de Scotté l'a
coupé le robinet aux habitants qui ne
sont pas dans sa juridiction car la
ville doit réduire sa propre
consommation d'eau d'au moins 5%
qui livre de l'eau depuis une vingtaine
d'années il a vu la région se sécher
il est perçu comme un sauveur ici il a
cinq camions c'est un des plus gros
transporteurs d'eau dans la région
[Applaudissements]
à faire le plein à scottail dit-il et
ravitailler mes clients en une heure
maintenant il faut que j'aille plus loin
le même service me prend 3 à 4h et ça
coûte 3 fois plus cher
il ne peut pas servir autant de clients
qu'avant
pour les résidents de Rio veut les
futurs la situation est insupportable
[Musique]
ne pensait jamais se retrouver dans une
telle situation elle vit ici avec son
mari depuis 2016
que j'ai conçu moi-même
elle venait de faire remplir son
réservoir en décembre elle n'a pas de
puits et dépend des livres d'eau mais
depuis janvier c'est le rationnel elle
utilise avec son mari 51 litres d'eau
par jour la moyenne pour un couple est
de 300 litres par jour
on prend notre douche une fois tous les
quatre jours dit-elle
on a eu beaucoup de pluie
j'utilise cette eau pour rincer la
vaisselle et pour les toilettes
même scénario chez Steven cognerus
médecin et Donald rice physicienne tous
les deux à la retraite
ils ont quitté l'Alaska pour vivre dans
le désert
on fait pipi dehors dit-il on utilise
des assiettes en papier pour manger et
on s'est inscrit dans un club de Jim
pour prendre nos douches
et si c'était à refaire il n'achèterait
pas ici
un peu plus loin le ranch meler abrite
une quarantaine de chevaux
impossible de les rationner
il consomme plus de 4000 litres d'eau
par jour
il partage son temps entre Berlin et Rio
Verdez il a acheté le rang qui a une
quinzaine d'années et depuis le puits
s'est asséché il se fait livrer l'eau
pour remplir ces deux réservoirs mais
les prix ont presque triplés
je pourrais acheter du San Pellegrino je
vous dit-il ça coûterait moins cher
à cette station d'eau au nord de phénix
les habitants n'ont pas de problème
d'eau c'est la compagnie canadienne
upcool un des plus gros fournisseurs
d'eau réglementés dans la région qui la
leur fournie
ici les camions-citernes débordent l'eau
ne provient pas du Canada mais de
différentes sources dans la région dont
le fleuve Colorado
d'avoir le permis pour approvisionner
aussi les habitants de riovelle
Wesley
c'est une solution à long terme dit-elle
et ça risque de prendre deux à trois ans
pour installer l'infrastructure
en attendant les résidents de Rio veut
les foods sont livrés à eux-mêmes pour
avoir de l'eau en payant parfois
l'équivalent de leur hypothèque
mais le maire est sans équivoque pas
question d'utiliser l'eau de Scott stare
j'entends de profiter de nos ressources
dit-il alors que leur lotissement sont
pas dans notre juridiction
ici on se plaît à répéter le célèbre
dicton le whisky sert à boire mais l'eau
à se battre
le fleuve Colorado s'assèche forçant
Washington à imposer des restrictions au
Nevada à l'Arizona à la Californie
et pour le moment on a l'impression que
le message n'est pas passé par tout
la région regorge de terrain de golf qui
attire les touristes l'eau coule
impunément
des boulevards avec du gazon dit-il ça
n'a pas de sens on vit dans le désert
quand même
on continue à construire des maisons
alors qu'il n'y a plus d'eau nous on
nous précise que toutes les nouvelles
maisons ont un pieux c'est tout le
paradoxe des États dans la région
la situation à Rio veut les photos est
un avant-goût de ce qui pourrait se
passer dans tout le Sud-Ouest américain
est le premier domino à tomber dit-il
nous sommes le premier groupe à souffrir
des ramifications de la sécheresse
les gens considèrent l'eau comme une
ressource précieuse utile et non pas
comme un bien illimité car tôt ou tard
cette pénurie d'eau ne va faire que
s'amplifier et affecter un plus grand
nombre de personnes dans la région ici
azayer Radio-Canada Arizona